comment ça va regardez aujourd'hui on
vient parler d'audio je vais vous
présenter un truc qui est super
intéressant c'est de la marque sonoro
aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo qui réalise
un partenariat avec sonoro c'est écrit
sur mon gant c'est les gants qui
fournissent avec ça c'est très cool
c'est une solution c'est un 7 complet
qui vient regrouper le maestro le
maestro c'est un amplificateur et un
lecteur tout en un j'ai tout vous
expliquer les super intéressant vous
avez de la radio Internet vous avez
plein de possibilités vous avez co buzz
vous avez Spotify vous avez le lecteur
CD bref c'est génial c'est vraiment
complet et vous avez les Orchestra les
orchestrales ce sont les deux gros
enceintes que vous avez également ici la
solution est géniale pour la maison et
en plus ici on a une finition en noyer
qui est tout simplement magnifique donc
c'est une vidéo aujourd'hui qui a
réalisé en partenariat avec sonoro pour
vous présenter cette solution et si vous
cherchez une solution audio à la maison
extrêmement complète très facile
d'utilisation et bien vous allez voir
elle est géniale et une fois de plus je
vous mets le lien juste en bas dans la
description
avant toute chose est-ce que vous
connaissez la marque sonoro alors sonoro
c'est une marque d'audio allemande qui
était fondée en 2006 qui propose des
produits audio de qualité au niveau de
la finition au niveau de la fabrication
qualité dans le choix des matériaux et
avec un design exigeant et bien
évidemment un son exception on s'en
doutera puisque ici on parle de duo
c'est logique et si je vous présente un
pack qui est intéressant avec maestro et
Orchestra alors ici vous avez des
finitions en noyer on peut y retrouver
indépendamment les orchestrales et le
maestro dans d'autres finition mais
celle que je vous présente ici en noyer
se trouve juste extrêmement canon on a
un design un temporel élégant bref un
super produit hifi pour la maison on a
donc deux éléments extrêmement
importants ici vous avez le maestro qui
se situe juste là qui est très joli
c'est à la fois l'amplificateur c'est à
la fois un lecteur tout-en-un et vous
avez les Orchestra finition noyée d'un
côté comme de l'autre ici Orchestra sont
des enceintes bibliothèques basse
réflexes à deux voies avec un cash
haut-parleur qui est magnétique donc si
vous voulez l'enlever vous pouvez pour
avoir ça comme ça je trouve ça
extrêmement joli c'est super élégant à
vous de voir à la maison si vous voulez
le cache oui ou non au choix tout en
sachant que vous avez un complet
directement sur le site de sonoro à 2498
euros avec le maestro et les Orchestra
en finition noyées ils existent
également individuellement dans d'autres
finitions mais la noyée comme ça ça
trouve très jolie intemporel et juste
extrêmement classe d'ailleurs si vous
voulez acheter le pack sur le site de
sonoro je vous mets le lien en bas dans
la description le pack va être livré
avec 6 mètres de câble d'enceinte du
fabricant gold kabble modèle speaker
Flex alors on se concentre sur le
maestro le Maestro est juste super beau
vous avez un design en bois de noyer qui
est poli à la main et qui est
extrêmement doux au toucher avec de
véritables éléments en aluminium sur les
touches et les boutons en façade boîtier
compact appareil complet et surtout avec
un design qui est très minimaliste vous
avez ici une partie avec un lecteur CD
le bouton pour l'allumer et l'éteindre
l'infrarouge prise jack 3.5 pour bien
brancher un casque on peut également
avoir un casque en bluetooth mais je
vous en parle dans quelques instants
parti de commande du CD un écran couleur
agrégation automatique de 2,8 pouces de
diagonale c'est du LCD des boutons
raccourcis pour dire accéder à vos
fonctions principales l'AFM dab plus la
radio Internet le Bluetooth auxiliaire
digital les favoris CD phono également
différents services notamment Spotify
tidal Napster Deezer cobles Amazon Music
et même un lecteur média et quelques
petits boutons très simples sur le côté
OK pour valider cette pour rentrer dans
vos paramètres le bouton retour et votre
molette pour naviguer et moduler le son
maestro c'est un ampli de type IPEX de
classe D qui peut envoyer aux Orchestra
deux fois 170 watts en quatre Roms ou
deux fois 100 watts en 8 oh alors ici ce
qui est vachement bien c'est qu'il est
extrêmement polyvalent vous avez
différentes sources on peut mettre un CD
alors je me suis pris un bon vieux CDD
cranberries histoire de se faire plaisir
que vous en douterez à cause des
problèmes de droit d'auteur je peux pas
venir vous mettre les cranberries ici
sans quoi ça me bloquerait sur la chaîne
on va éviter mais ce qui est génial
c'est que vous avez plein de sources
d'une RFM dab plus la radio Internet
plus de 25000 stations dispo dans le
monde entier et des tonnes de podcasts
et comme ça n'apparaît qui est très
polyvalent vous avez un max de
connectique on a un port USB 5 volts 2,1
ampères pour venir recharger si c'est
pratique une entrée auxiliaire avec un
jack 3.5 une très lignes RCA plaqué or
une entrée phono pour cartouche mn des
entrées numériques optiques et coaxial
une prise directe ça je vous l'ai montré
3.5 pour sortir avec votre casque une
presse sortie RCA plaqué or pour venir
brancher un caisson de basse par exemple
et si les bornes des haut-parleurs sont
également plaqués Or et vous avez un
câble d'alimentation avec marquage de
phase ok classique ce qui est génial
avec tous ces ports c'est que vous avez
beaucoup de possibilités une vraie
flexibilité au niveau l'utilisation et
vous pouvez même venir brancher votre
téléviseur dessus pour l'avoir en sortie
audio et comme je vous le disais vous
avez vos services de streaming Spotify
tidal Napster Amazon music cow-boys
Deezer et vous vous connectez bien
évidemment en Bluetooth grâce au
Qualcomm APTX et on va voir essayer du
Bluetooth bidirectionnel pour pouvoir
envoyer le signal vous de votre appareil
directement à maestro et lui il va
pouvoir envoyer le signal sortant
directement de maestro vers un casque
Bluetooth ou alors utiliser un casque
filaire à vous de voir et si on ne veut
pas venir utiliser un casque ce que je
vous conseille quand même vous avez les
enceintes Orchestra les orchestrales
sont aussi extrêmement jolies vous
pouvez la voir comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure avec votre cash ici ou
alors vous faites le choix de l'enlever
et vous voyez votre noyée qui apparaît
ici et je trouve une fois de plus
extrêmement élégant ça dépendra de ce
qui est cool c'est que c'est aimanté
vous le prenez vous le posez ça tient
tout seul on se parle bien ici
d'enceinte bibliothèque basse réflexe à
deux voies ce que mes sonoro ici en
avant c'est la qualité audio bien
évidemment avec l'utilisation de coffret
en bois assemblés ici tout est poli
méticuleusement à la main on a une image
sonore authentique avec un son détaillé
et ample ici vous avez un haut-parleur
grave médium avec double aimant néodyme
et vous avez un Twitter dit AMT r motion
Transformers ici le coffret des
haut-parleur est composé d'un panneau de
fibres à haute densité avec un câblage
et des fibres développées sur mesure
pour fonctionner de manière optimale
avec votre maestro les connectiques à
l'arrière sont aussi très jolis très
facile d'utilisation et on garde ce côté
aussi très élégant et puis il y a un
truc qui est vachement bien comme sonoro
aime les solutions connectées les
solutions intelligentes pour la maison
ils ont développé une application qui
vous permettra de calibrer votre système
audio par rapport à votre pièce alors je
sais pas si vous êtes au coutumier de
l'audio mais chaque pièce va raisonner
différemment la réverbération sera
différente en fonction des éléments en
fonction des meubles de votre pièce et
en fonction des murs également sans
doutera d'où l'idée de l'application
sonoro room correction alors
l'application ici elle existe uniquement
sur I pas sur Android donc si vous avez
un Android foncé acheter un iphone ou
alors vous n'utiliserez pas
l'application regardez je vous montre
comment ça se passe dans votre
application il va venir retrouver votre
maestro ici j'appuie dessus maestro et
j'arrive directement sur les paramètres
je vois la correction de la pièce en
rouge c'était avant en vert et après et
après vous pouvez venir calibrer pour la
première fois vous appuyez sur commencer
la correction ça vous envoie un bruit
blanc directement au travers de vos
enceintes ce que vous faites c'est que
vous vous baladez dans la pièce avec
votre smartphone qui lui va se connecter
et il va être utilisé comme un micro
vous incite à venir vraiment vous
déplacer vous balader comme ça il va
venir connaitre et corriger l'audio et
l'adapter surtout à votre intérieur et
sonoro vous propose également une
application qui s'appelle un doc ou un
doc à vous de voir comme vous voulez le
prononcer ça dépendra on va dire un doc
dans l'application vous retrouverez ce
qui est en lecture actuellement puis
vous avez vos différentes sources vous
allez pouvoir venir aller dessus
switcher directement entre la FM la date
plus la radio Internet la musique locale
le Bluetooth les différentes entrées le
CD Spotify compagnie j'en passe et des
meilleurs c'est plutôt sympa plutôt bien
fait mais pour venir l'utiliser ce que
je vous recommande quand même c'est de
passer par la télécommande qui est
également et très complète la
télécommande est très simple claire bien
conçu vous allez retrouver ici votre
bouton pour l'allumer les réglages c'est
top le miloute votre sélection de source
qui est juste ici la navigation valide
ok play pause on avance au recul le
volume au centre qui est un peu
différent et c'est bien parce que ça
vient un peu casser le look de la
télécommande les basses les cue le
tribal un petit pavé tactile si besoin
l'info sleep et compagnie bref elle est
très simple très clair et surtout en
terme de prise en main elle est aussi
hyper canon on va se l'écouter un petit
peu pour regarder ce que ça donne alors
je fais gaffe parce que j'ai pas les
droits mais je vous faire profiter de la
meilleure expérience alors on se met un
petit bout de cranberry histoire de se
marrer mais très très rapidement vous
voyez ça part comme ça je peux vraiment
pas donc la musique mais la qualité
audio est vraiment là c'est rond c'est
beau c'est classe ça fonctionne bien
donc ça c'est chouette regardez on va
switcher on va passer ici sur la radio
DAB ça c'est très cool également là on
est sur Jazz Radio donc c'est pareil on
va quand même faire aussi extrêmement
gaffe je vais éviter de vous mettre Jazz
Radio je n'ai pas les droits là-dessus
mais le truc qui est très cool si on
vient switcher juste à côté on va voir
la radio Internet et là il y a plein de
trucs il y a plein de podcasts on va
écouter c'est quoi ça c'est un podcast
international vous voyez donc là on se
met un petit podcast donc si vous voulez
venir écouter un petit podcast c'est
chouette en plus sur l'écran c'est très
très cool également vous avez la
pochette du podcast avec la tête de la
personne qui fait le podcast bien
évidemment toutes les informations qui
défilent la durée compagnie enfin c'est
très très sûr qu'on a toutes les
informations sous les yeux et si on veut
la voyez je peux revenir en arrière et
je vais voir la liste de toutes mes
radios Internet les préférés les locales
en France les stations les podcasts mais
ça sont ajoutés bref il y en a
énormément c'est très clair très lisible
et ça c'est très très cool et puis après
j'ai mes différentes entrées genre mon
Bluetooth sauf s'il y a digital et
j'enlève sur mon CD ici si je dois
remettre l'écran de berries on va se
mettre un petit morceau j'ai quoi par
exemple là vous voyez on est sur nonit
tu vois Rio on va se mettre un petit
zombie ça va être le quatrième morceau
et puis voilà qu'on a fini en beauté
avec zombie des Cranberries normalement
c'est très cool en terme de son c'est
bien ça marche bien ça va envoyer on va
faire gaffe quand ça va partir ça va
partir fort c'est hyper chouette et on
fait gaffe parce que bon voilà une fois
de plus on va pas venir s'attirer des
problèmes avec les badjor ici c'est pas
le but donc voyez pour cette solution ce
7 ce pack maestro sonoro finition noyé
que je trouve extrêmement jolie le gros
point positif de cette solution déjà
c'est la compacité et la puissance que
vous avez au niveau de maestro c'est
également la puissance qui est développé
grâce aux Orchestra produit qui est très
beau qui est très élégant qui est
compact et surtout extrêmement
polyvalent avec beaucoup de sources avec
beaucoup de connectiques je trouve très
chouette donc si vous intéresse bien
évidemment et bien je vous mets un lien
juste en bas dans la description aller
chez un œil et puis dites-moi ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire est-ce que
vous connaissez sur neuro est-ce que
vous avez déjà des produits de sonoro
est-ce qu'un pack comme celui-là
pourrait vous tenter dites le moi juste
en bas dans les commentaires et on se
retrouve très bientôt pour continuer à
parler tech d'audio mais pas que et ça
c'est chouette je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous et à bientôt avec cranberry
je vous sens et on va quand même faire
gaffe on va avoir des problèmes allez
bisous Ciao
[Musique]